last night the Associated Press reported
that Senate Democrats Bill to write Roe
v Wade into law blocked by gop-led
filibuster as Supreme Court ways
abortion case that was the AP headline
MSNBC similarly reported that a GOP LED
filibuster derailed the bill to codify
Roe v Wade protections and since the AP
and MSNBC reported it you will not be
surprised to find out that that is not
true the Democrats abortion Bill failed
by a vote of 49-51.
that is not a filibuster the filibuster
is a tool to delay or block legislation
in the Senate it has been used by both
parties and defended by both parties
including people who are now in the
leadership of both parties many many
times throughout history but it was not
used here because you don't need to use
the filibuster if the other side can't
even win a simple majority of votes for
their bill
I obviously do not put it past MSNBC and
the AP to lie but in their defense I
also wouldn't be surprised if the genius
is running those news organizations
simply didn't know what the word
filibuster means regardless contrary to
what the AP and MSNBC reported the bill
did not fail because of Any strange
rules any chicanery it failed because
most Senators voted against it and most
Senators voted against it because it
would have outlawed virtually every
abortion restriction in the country
it actually did not seek to codify Roe v
Wade into law if that's all the bill had
sought to do the bill almost certainly
would have passed because squishy
Republicans like Susan Collins and Lisa
murkowski almost certainly would have
voted for it
the bill went further because Democrats
have adopted an extreme position on
abortion that has absolutely no basis in
the American legal tradition and almost
no currency among the American people
just six percent of whom support it
which is why they're taking to the
streets and throwing Molotov cocktails
Through the Windows of pro-life
pregnancy centers and screaming in front
of the houses of Supreme Court Justices
and scaring their kids in the middle of
the night
the pro-abortion movement cannot seem to
gain any more power it can't seem even
to hold on to the power that it already
has
in the ordinary political process
so now they're looking outside the
political process to mob Justice in
residential neighborhoods I'm Michael
nolasus the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
foreign
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from Kevin Springer
who says the leftist says this country
is not a Christian Nation to which I say
our money literally says In God We Trust
yes it does not just our money we have a
pledge of allegiance we say I pledge
allegiance to the flag of the United
States of America and to the Republic
for which it stands one nation under God
our earliest national holiday in this
country is Thanksgiving to whom do you
think they were giving thanks it's
pretty clear actually later on George
Washington tells us to whom they were
giving thanks
our other national holiday the Fourth of
July what what does that commemorate
commemorates the Declaration of
Independence what is the Declaration of
Independence say we hold these truths to
be self-evident that all men are created
equal and endowed by their creator who's
that Creator we're talking about the big
guy we're talking about God it's it's a
completely a historical argument to say
that America is not a Christian Nation
to say that Christianity is not the
animating Spirit of America it has been
from the very beginning and and so what
the libs try to do is they take one or
two lines from a private letter of
Thomas Jefferson or the Treaty of
Tripoli where we were trying to convince
Muslim Pirates to stop stealing our
Sailors and and they take them
completely out of the historical and
philosophical context of the country and
it leads people astrays lots of wish
casting from the secular left
now speaking of very zealous leftists
you know we've had this this scourge of
uh protesters outside of the Supreme
Court Justices homes
yelling screaming doing all sorts of
nasty things waking up the justices
families in the middle of the night
we've seen violent pro-abortion
demonstrations in the rest of the
country Wisconsin Oregon Maryland
throwing Molotov cocktails vandalism
graffiti all sorts of things
I want to make sure that we're not just
in an echo chamber here we're not just
talking to ourselves so I'm bringing on
someone who I suspect is more reasonable
than Joe Biden I hope he's more
reasonable than Joe Biden this would be
David pakman David coming back to the
show a nationally syndicated Progressive
talk show host on TV and radio David
thank you for coming back to the show
the the first time went so well I had to
come back for seconds I knew it that's I
that's that's why we invited you back
and listen I
I'm I was disheartened to see that Joe
Biden and jensaki would not condemn the
protests at all hours outside of the
justices homes in residential
neighborhoods before their families I
suspect I mean I mean this sincerely I'm
not being facetious at all I suspect you
are more reasonable than the staffers at
the White House now can we at least
agree
this is bad it is bad to protest outside
of Supreme Court Justices homes
well so do I suspect you want to have a
good faith conversation about this is
that a fair assessment so we can speak
freely here you're not just looking to
play gotcha here I'm not no I I okay all
right that's not what we do on the show
so let's see
um I this is not a protest technique I
would employ right but I have a large
platform online where I'm going to reach
way more people than going to anybody's
house so like my personal thing is this
is not a protest technique I would
employ let's go through like legality
morality ethics Etc yep anything that is
a criminal act like a Molotov cocktail
uh destruction of property what whatever
it should be reported if there's a crime
people should be charged if you can get
ability guilty verdict they should be
you know sentenced fine very very good
in terms of the speech aspect of this
you know there's this case from the 90s
Madison V Women's Health Center
which found that it's okay for
anti-choice protesters to go and protest
outside the homes of just random workers
at abortion clinics okay now that's not
my opinion that's a decision that exists
those are quite literally private
citizens they're just like medical
workers right so if that's okay and we
have a First Amendment certainly showing
up and protesting isn't against the law
are you and I on the same page about
that piece no because in the U.S code 18
U.S code section 1507 the law the
federal law explicitly prohibits
protesting outside of the homes of
Judges with the intention of influencing
their decisions so if they were Vision
has been done though no it hasn't the
decision hasn't come out there was a
leaked draft of the opinion so I I would
agree with you it's not clear that they
were in violation of the law if the
decision had already come out and they
were just expressing their anger but
because the decision has not come out
because it seems clear to me that the
protesters are trying to change the the
course of how this decision is going to
come and try to bring political pressure
to me it seems quite clear this is a
violation of federal law no no lawyer
I've spoken to says that this is against
any law unless unless some specific you
know if there even if even something as
relatively benign as a noise ordinance
let's say there's a noise ordinance that
starts at 10 pm if it's 11 and you're
being loud okay now that's something to
talk about but there's there's I I know
that's not the law that I know who says
there's any law being broken here that
that is the law I mean the viewers are
free to go check it out but that is a
very specific law there's also there's
actually a Virginia Statute too but I'm
just talking about the federal law 18
USC 1507 you can look it up now you
might say well I don't like that law I
don't think it's just I think it's
applicable here and I just don't think
it's applicable at the homes of these
individuals in Virginia based on lawyers
I've spoken to neither you or I are
lawyers so we may just be further the
statute is plain are you saying that you
don't think that the the protesters are
seeking to influence the decision
I haven't spoken to them so I really
can't say but you can hear what they're
saying right what's that you can hear
the sort of things that they're chanting
they're not saying I actually have not
heard what their chance I don't know
what they're what are they chanting you
tell me they're chanting my body my
choice they're chant they're chanting uh
you know my body my choice isn't changed
the the decision of course it is that's
just their opinion right my body my
children they're chanting in support of
the of the ruling that will be overruled
by the Dobbs versus Jackson Women's
Health Organization case I think that if
we want to get into the minutia of this
at the legal level yeah I think you
would have a hard time arguing that
legally saying my body my choice is
equivalent to saying change your
decision so I don't know why why what
would they be doing outside of the
justices homes before a decision comes
out after a leakage continuing their
opinion I mean listen their opinion
you're going to win on that I don't
think you're going to win on legal lead
they were breaking the law because they
said my body my choice it seems very
weak no David they're not merely saying
my body my choice and they're not merely
posting some opinion online they're
going to the homes of these people that
actually the group that sent them it's
called Ruth sent us they said that this
is an unacceptable attack on women and
LGBT and we need to force them right
that was the key word we need to force
them to change their views using a
diversity of tactics and we would
acknowledge that peaceful protesting is
just one tactic so it seems like they're
calling for other things but but even
that word what is that word Michael now
you're blending now you're saying well
they've used peaceful protesting but
they're calling for other things no no
but so they've broken that isn't my
problem no no I mean I think that that
is a separate issue but the very fact
that the organization I'm sorry
that's that's a problem as well that
they're calling for a diversity of
tactics but the chief problem that we're
discussing here is that the organization
that is taking responsibility for
sending the mobs to the justices homes
says we need to force them to change
their minds we need to force them to not
attack women in LGBT and all of the
other uh minority groups that they're
discussing so even the word force would
suggest to me that that they are
attempting to influence the decision and
therefore are in violation of this law
yeah I I I'm not trying to skirt the
main point you're trying to make which I
am unsure I can identify but I haven't
seen that specifically said so it's just
hard for me to comment on it what I
think all right you're pleading you're
pleading uh pleading ignorance on this
point no I'm not pleading ignorance but
what what I can speak to is if any crime
has been committed charge them okay I'm
totally with that I'm totally with that
yeah okay that makes sense do you think
now from your perspective as a
reasonable Democrat if you were advising
Democrats I'm not a Democrat I've never
been associated with the Democratic
party really
are you in any party or you're just
independent no yeah I'm just independent
would you you would generally vote for
Democrats I would assume I vote for more
Democrats than Republicans I don't care
about parties though I see parties
essentially almost like corporations
that justify their own existence to just
continue existing in opposition to the
other other party do you do you really
vote for republicans
I voted for many in there's lots of
nonpartisan local elections okay where I
later found out some of the people were
not Democrats but I mean it's kind of
neither here nor there okay so but
you're not formally in the Democrat
Party if you were advising a Democratic
candidate or any candidate for that
matter who is on the left would you
advise them to continue running on this
issue of abortion on this issue of well
for instance the bill that the Democrats
last night tried to pass it failed in
the Senate to they said it was to codify
Roe versus Wade it actually went further
to create even more abortion protections
would you advise them to run on this
issue in the midterms or to back away
from it in the midterms I so run on it I
think that there's two from a political
strategy standpoint there's two options
one would be run on the bill that failed
yesterday that doesn't seem like a good
idea to run on that
um I I think where there is based on
public opinion about abortion being as
in favor of it as ever before during the
Roe v Wade era public polling is now in
the 60 70 percent of Americans believe
abortion should generally be legal in
most cases that that not in every case
but in most cases based on that it seems
to me it would be prudent to run on we
need to get the government out of
medical decisions between women and
doctors I mean and again you're I you
and I are never going to agree on
something like when does Life Begin
that's the difference
you know I had a gal who hold on but let
me at least finish my sentence sure you
asked me about strategy it seems to me
that since most Americans think think
abortion should be legal in most cases
the right strategy thing would be we
need to get the federal government out
of in the middle of these medical
decisions but but right now if you if
you let's say that the leaked opinion
actually ends up being the final
decision let's say that Roe v Wade is
overruled instantly as Elizabeth Warren
says abortion is severely restricted if
not outlawed in more than half of the
states instantly you you've you've
you're in a very different situation
knowing that the there are all sorts of
polls there's polls that show that 94 of
Americans reject the absolutist view of
abortion held by some Democrats their
polls as you cite that show that when
you ask the question do you support Roe
versus Wade broadly then there is some
majority of Americans that broadly want
some abortion uh liberality so Michael
that's very mealy mouth I mean let's
be honest
it asks the same way over the last 50
years support for Roe v Wade has
continued to go up fair well it depends
how you ask the question if you ask the
same way over the last video right if
you ask that it has gone up if you ask
the question in a way that is uh I think
hiding the reality of abortion and is
just talking about the decision Roe
versus Wade then sure there's broad
support for it but if you but if you ask
the question and you say do you support
this type of abortion do you support
this type of abortion do you support
then the support is much much smaller
this is this is why 80 Bill failed
yesterday you're creating distinctions
only to create doubt when the the point
I'm making is
over the last 50 years generally overall
should abortion generally be legal in
most cases but the work has gone up but
you can admit that and still be against
it no but David the problem is the devil
is in the details because I mean I've
got a poll right here that that goes
into depth on different aspects of
abortion polling that I'm not depending
on how you change it depending on how
you phrase the question if you get very
different answers so I guess my point is
this according to some of this polling
very few very few voters and very very
few independent voters okay support
abortion as a top policy issue it it
does not seem to motivate a whole lot of
people to go to the polls it was it fair
I would agree with that I agree with
that so therefore in that case if you
were advising these candidates you know
you you might say okay just keep using
the same lines the Democrats have used
since Roe versus Wade but if you were
talking about focusing a campaign I
think there are a lot of Democrats right
now who say we're going to run on this
this is going to motivate everyone to go
to the polls make your campaign about
abortion would you say that's a good
strategy or would you say hey maybe back
off a little bit and talk about I don't
know gas prices
no no no I don't think that's a good
strategy I mean again this is less about
my opinion but it's about what the facts
showed the facts show that economic
issues are far more important when it
comes to running National campaigns so I
mean no disagreement there these are
these are just strategy questions yeah
absolutely sure there's also there was
polling that came out yesterday that
showed that on the abortion question in
as much as it does motivate people it's
actually the Roe v Wade overruling seems
to be uh propelling Republicans at
almost 2x the rate as Democrats so
anyway listen I know David I knew that
you would be much more reasonable than
uh Joe Biden uh David that's all the
time we have thank you very much for
coming on those oh my God it's over we
haven't even talked about anything we've
got well no I think I think as I I would
give you a compliment but uh thankfully
that's missing too I think that you've
presented a more reasonable view than
the White House has I think you've
presented better political advice than
the White House has for their own party
and so I appreciate you for coming on uh
where can people find you
uh davidpackman.com I can't imagine a
more meaningful compliment and praise
than that coming from you Michael thank
you David thanks for coming on now
listen folks we need to protect not just
our families not just our rule of law
not just our institutions we've got to
protect our homes that's why you need a
ring right now go to ring.com Knowles
you know how much I love ring I've been
talking about ring for years they have
been supporting this show basically
since the very beginning and it started
with that ring video doorbell which is
great you get to see and speak to
whoever is at your doorstep whether
you're in your home at the office on the
beach somewhere then I told you about
ring alarm so ring alarm allows you to
protect your whole home the windows the
doors you can protect from freeze fire
flood all the bad guys well now my
friends now you've got to go pro ring
alarm Pro does not just protect your
physical home you live in your physical
home we got physical bodies you got to
protect that it protects your digital
home too we live so much of Our Lives
online in the virtual reality that
you've got to protect that Wi-Fi router
ring alarm Pro according to CNET is a
giant leap for home security you're
going to find out why B be a pro like me
GoPro with ring it's absolutely great
makes me feel so comfortable when I'm in
the home when I'm away from the home to
learn more go to ring.com Knowles that's
ring.com Knowles you know David wouldn't
give me the point any kind of pled
ignorance on this aspect of the federal
law which is pretty clear by the way it
says very explicitly you cannot protest
outside the judge assumption influence
the decisions but he I think he conceded
the broader point which is yeah I
wouldn't use this tactic yeah I don't
think this is very effective yeah I
don't if they broke a law you know let's
arrest them and sweep them to the
fringes it would probably be wise for uh
Democrats to do this because this this
is a loser for them they thought leaking
the opinion was going to Galvanize
support it hasn't it's had the opposite
effect
they thought protesting outside the
judge's homes
was going to Galvanize support
it's had the opposite effect they
thought I mean I think the purpose of
leaking that opinion was to codify Roe
versus Wade into law and pass a National
Abortion bill they tried that it failed
and it didn't even fail because of the
filibuster it failed because they
couldn't even get a bare majority of
people to vote for it and so now they're
left screaming into the void uh there
was a I don't know his name there was a
guy who popped up some Dash something uh
he popped up on Twitter he went viral
yesterday some people said he looked
like a deep fake of me like a kind of
Bizarro World version of me and he uh
expressed what I think is the very
common anger and very incoherent anger
of the libs over Roe v Wade
I have a question for the Department of
Justice when Amy Coney Barrett said
she'd uphold Roe v Wade in her
confirmation hearing she lied lying
under oath is perjury and perjury is a
federal crime why didn't you take any
legal action against her
when Neil Gorsuch said he'd uphold Roe v
Wade in his confirmation hearing he lied
lying under oath is perjury and perjury
is a federal crime why didn't you take
any legal action against him when Brett
Kavanaugh said he'd uphold Roe v Wade
and his confirmation hearing he lied
lying under oath is perjury and perjury
is a federal crime why didn't you take
any legal action against him
Merrick Garland your decision not to
prosecute is going to cost women in
America their Reproductive Rights how
dare you call yourself the Department of
Justice do your job prosecute the
Republican justices
Mr Garland how dare you call yourself
the depart does he call himself that I
don't think he does well they committed
perjury no they didn't dude dude the
libs not know what basic words mean what
what basic legal concepts are they don't
know what the filibuster is they don't
know the political concept they don't
know what perjury is
but this is a common refrain now that
you're hearing from the libs that Amy
Barrett and Brett Kavanaugh Neil Gorsuch
perjured themselves because of what they
said in their confirmation hearings
about Roe v Wade well what did they say
I've got it here I've got it from
factcheck.org which is sort of a isn't
that the left-wing organization I think
it is but they have the exact words here
and what did they say
Gorsuch said that Roe was precedent
he wouldn't even say that it was super
president he said this is precedent
a senator I would tell you Roe v Wade
decided in 1973 as a president of the
United States Supreme Court it has been
reaffirmed the Reliance interest
considerations are important there and
all of the other factors that go into
analyzing precedent have to be
considered it is a precedent of the U.S
Supreme Court it was reaffirmed in Casey
in 1992. so a good judge will consider
it as precedent of the U.S Supreme Court
worthy as treatment of precedent like
any others and Kavanaugh and Barrett did
the same thing
they didn't say I will uphold Roe v Wade
I will uphold Planned Parenthood by
Casey they said it is precedent it
should be treated as other precedents
are and sometimes you uphold precedence
and sometimes you overrule precedence
and all the Senators during their
confirmationaries wanted the the judges
to say I hate Roe v Wade but they
wouldn't say that because they were
smart and they wanted to get on the
court so they just said yes wrote it was
it'd be as if they said Roe v Wade is
Roe v Wade yes and Planned Parenthood V
Casey is Planned Parenthood vkc and Roe
v Wade has uh three words in it Roe
versus Wade and one of those words
starts with an r and the other with a V
and the other with a W and that is my
opinion of Roe versus Wade and that's
what they said and now they're going to
overrule it it was a precedent might not
be a very important precedent for much
longer
this issue I got into a little bit with
David this is a loser not just in terms
of where the support is David made the
point that Roe v Wade the concept of Roe
v Wade is popular enough but abortion
itself is not very popular which is why
you've got to go into the details and
why you've got to change the wording
from the way Democrats have in the polls
to the way Republicans doing the polls
and then you've got the motivation
Factor people are simply not motivated
by this issue at all only one in five
independent voters according to new
polling by the RNC obtained exclu first
by the daily wire one in five
independent voters say abortion is the
main factor for them in determining a
candidate only 16 percent of independent
voters said abortion should be allowed
at any time during the mother's
pregnancy for any reason when you add
Republicans to that number then the
number goes down to six percent of the
electorate so it's it's the top issue
for only nine percent of Voters it's a
loser Democrats I mean keep it up you're
only winning votes for for Republicans
at this point you're only winning
support for the overrule of Roe versus
Wade but you are not helping your own
side
all right now speaking of life and death
you got to go check out fabric right now
go to meet fabric.com
Knowles do the responsible thing parents
okay time to finally cross off one of
the most important things on your to-do
list that's life insurance fabric makes
getting a great term life insurance
policy for your family quick
easy surprisingly affordable fabric was
built specifically for parents to help
you manage your family's financial
future like a parenting Pro stress free
Fabric's new lower prices means
significant savings over other providers
with great policies like a million
dollars in coverage for less than a
dollar a day everything is on your
schedule with fabric because it's all
online less than 10 minutes to apply you
could be offered coverage instantly no
Health exam required just personalize
your quote to fit your family's needs
you will be set with high quality
affordable protection for your family
you will sleep easier at night you will
have done the responsible thing it's
backed by vantus life really really
important to do right now you got a
30-day money-back guarantee protect your
family with term life insurance now in
just 10 minutes apply at meetfabric.com
Knowles that's meatfabric.com how do you
spell it m-e-e-t fabric.com slash
Knowles fabric Insurance Agency policies
issued by vantus life not available in
New York and Montana price is subject to
underwriting and health questions the
weird sex stuff does not play for Dems
whether we're talking about abortion or
whether we're talking about
gender or transgender or orientations or
all sorts of sexual issues you know that
the number of genders is Multiplied in
recent years from 2 to 56 to 75
. now there's a new gender I found one
yesterday
I had never heard of it before
that would be cake gender
okay I would describe xenogeners as a
gender that could not typically be
described with terms such as masculinity
femininity neutrality androgyny things
like that it's more of not how you
relate to a particular gender
experience but more of how you relate to
things
for example cake gender
um I know a few people who personally
use this
um it's typically described as them
feeling light and fluffy or sweet and
warm and it's not something that you
could typically describe with the terms
masculine feminine androgynous Etc
another example of cake gender would be
if someone feels like they have
different layers or flavors to their
particular gender
I'm I'm cannoli gender I'm a little
prickly on the outside maybe but really
soft and sweet in the middle you know
and full of chocolate chips actually too
every gender identity other than man and
woman is a euphemism for narcissism I
have come to realize every single one
you can be a man you can be a woman
before you become a man or a woman you
could be a boy or a girl
every other
gender identity is just a case of people
thinking about themselves too much it's
not that they think too much of
themselves necessarily it's that they
think of themselves too much and a man
wrapped up in himself makes a small
package indeed
cake gender the way that this lib who
brought to us of course by Libs of tick
tock the way that she describes cake
gender
is to say uh yeah I think that I'm uh
you know I'm sweet I think I'm a nice
person
I think I take I have some levity to me
and therefore that's a special gender
identity that makes me really special
and unique no you know most people are
kind of nice at least some of the time
most people can be sweet some of the
time most people have some levities that
most people laugh occasionally some of
the time that doesn't make you super
duper special okay it's a good thing
it's good to be encouraged but stop if
you just think about yourself and all
the ways that you're so super duper
special and so different from everybody
else there will be no end to that all
you will do like narcissus is just look
down at the mirror and just see yourself
and you won't be able to see all the
other beautiful stuff around the world
you won't be able to lift your eyes to
Heaven you won't be able to look around
at your community you're just going to
be thinking of you and that's not good
that's really that's going to drive you
crazy and the people who fall into this
stuff are crazy and they're behaving in
a really crazy way
and the way to stop it is to just just
stop thinking of yourself so much you
you are born with the facts of your
sexual identity
namely you're you're a boy or a girl a
man or a woman
that's that just accept that and move on
you do not need to discover or invent or
develop your sexual identity you've just
you've got it there you are those are
the parameters those are just like a
sonnet has limits just like all great
art has limits you those are your limits
and you have unique aspects to yourself
and you can develop your own personality
but you don't you don't need to reinvent
everything okay and actually when you
think about other people in the world
and when you move on when you can accept
the basic facts of life
that will hope that will free you to
think about more important things it
will help you to grow up which is really
what so much of this sexual Revolution
stuff is about
it's a bunch of people who are stuck and
stunted in their maturity at I don't
know the age of 12 or something and all
they're thinking about is the very base
level titillating kind of fleshy things
move on guys at a certain point we have
to grow up or we're going to have a
society of overgrown children which
which is unfortunately what we have and
it's not not leading
to lots of great things this is by the
way not I don't just want to beat up on
the people with the weird sex stuff we
all fall into this sometimes this is why
personality tests are so popular on the
internet you know am I an epdj or an ifp
am I what am I I'm such you're such a
Pisces you're such a capricorn yeah no I
took this test and I it's you're just
people do that the reason that
advertising agencies put put those tests
into websites is because they know that
you're extremely self-absorbed and they
know in this room most probably not you
you're the creme de La Creme you're
focused on if you're listening to this
show you're focused on broader things
but for a lot of people out there
they're extremely self-absorbed and they
click those links because they don't
really care about
um art or literature or politics or
things outside themselves they really
just care about themselves and they want
to talk more about themselves don't do
it folks it's super boring and silly and
embarrassing don't do that speaking of
narcissism one of the biggest Hollywood
Hollywood one of the biggest Broadway
Stars Patti LuPone just got caught on
audio
berating an audience member at one of
her shows because the audience member
was not wearing his mask in exactly the
way that Patti LuPone wanted him to
I just want to address one thing please
put your mask over your noses
right now did I have a mask on during
the show do you want me to put a mask on
because I will
your mask protects me so that I can
perform
all the time
push your mouth over your nose that's
why you're in the theater that is the
rule if you don't want to follow the
rule get the [ __ ] out
leave
what do you think you are that you do
not respect the people that are sitting
around you
you pay my salary
excuse me who do you think you are who
do you think you are do you think you're
like me the person not wearing a mask
the best part of it of course is that
she is not wearing a mask she's not
supposed to wear a mask she is a special
person she's famous she's even though
she's just a Broadway actress she's
probably got some you know she's
probably fairly wealthy she's goes to
very fancy parties she's celebrated she
doesn't have to do it Biden doesn't have
to wear a mask that's why he gets caught
without a mask all the times even when
he's making everyone else wear one Dr
fauci he doesn't have to wear a mask all
the celebrities at the Met gal or
anywhere else they don't need to wear
masks only the dirty filthy disgusting
staff who might spread their peasant
germs to the beautiful Elite people they
need to wear the mask and usually
usually the elites have the common sense
the common basic political
self-preservation instinct to not scream
at the unwashed masses in public Patti
LuPone like a lot of Broadway actresses
doesn't have a ton of control over her
emotions and so she goes and just
shrieks at this person says who Do You
Think You Are
do you think you're me
yeah I think that we have at least as
many political rights as you or at least
I think we should
and if you were really so concerned
about the the Wuhan flu then you just
wouldn't perform in the first place
you'd either wear a mask on stage or you
just wouldn't show up if this were
really such a grave threat to you
but it's not and you know it's not and
it's just a power trip and it might have
a little to do with Neurosis too
but we're not going to take that anymore
okay and I I give a lot of credit the
guy in that audience is the kind of guy
who would go see a Broadway show so
we're not I don't think that this was
some rock ribbed radical right-wing
Republican or anything this is the kind
of guy who will go to very left-wing
cultural events and he just said look
I'll put them but I'm not going to have
it over my nose and and I'm not going to
back down to you Patti LuPone I don't
think so the libs are totally totally
disconnected from reality at this point
do you remember a few weeks ago
few weeks ago
we heard that there might be some food
shortages in this country
we had an inkling that this was true
because well for one our grocery stores
have have had some weird stocking issues
supply chain hasn't been great to say
nothing a price is going through the
roof
and when we suggested that what happened
the libs called us conspiracy theories
theorists the libs said we were to
spreading far-right misinformation
disinformation oh whoops
not only do we have a food shortage we
have a shortage of baby formula
40 percent of all baby formula products
Nationwide are currently out of stock
that's according to CNN
the libs are blaming this on a recall of
products from this one Michigan plant
that's run by Avid nutrition
there's a question why is the plan why
was it shut down for so long why
couldn't they just resolve this issue
and then reopen it
the baby formula shortage is a big
problem because one not every baby can
breastfeed not every baby can latch not
every mother can produce milk
sometimes the mother can produce milk
but not enough milk so this is a real
problem when you've got a little
three-month-old baby the baby's got to
eat if you don't have formula that is
that is as acute a problem as there can
be in a country
the timing of this though really throws
it into Stark light
the conservatives right now are very
very worried that America won't be able
to feed its babies the conservatives are
trying to pass bills the conservatives
are writing writing to the heads of the
agencies like the FDA saying what's
going on
we need to we need to
make a more efficient process we need to
pass some emergency legislation we need
to get formula to the babies that's what
the conservatives are worried about
the Liberals are worried deathly afraid
that they won't be able to kill as many
babies anymore
the conservatives want to feed the
babies the libs want to kill the babies
the conservatives are proposing
legislation to feed the babies the libs
are proposing legislation to kill the
babies actually to kill more babies even
than you would see in a framework of Roe
versus Wade
which do you think is more popular
well we not we know because the abortion
Bill failed so we know that that's not
particularly popular
so why are they doing it why are they
doing it I think one they're really
trapped by their own ideology I think
two they're they're captive to their
radical radical base which wants
abortion on demand without apology and
three
I think it's just kind of the devil
folks I think you know it's kind of like
that bell curve meme where at the very
bottom of the belt like the really dumb
people on the bell curve they're just
like duh bad people collude with the
devil and then in the middle it's like
well no actually you know it's because
of all of these rationalist reasons and
then at the very top of the IQ bell
curve it's like no it's probably just
the devil I think I think that's kind of
what it is when you when you see people
crazed like Elizabeth Warren was fire in
her eyes fingers itching for the
tomahawk saying I'm so angry about Roe
versus Wade we're gonna stop it we're
gonna kill all these babies we're gonna
fight back against these babies that the
only way that I can explain that Mania
ultimately at a really deep level is
that evil is real there's a
personification of evil and people
collude with it that's it do I do I
sound like a crazy conspiracy theorist
no I think I sound like uh pretty much
every wise person throughout the history
of the world all of whom knew that good
and evil are real things and have real
personalities and we have some relation
to them
okay there's a uh a former Ohio state
senator a blue check on Twitter Nina
Turner who is actually she's actually
taken it all the way
to its logical conclusion and has said
look there's a baby formula shortage and
Roe v Wade might be overruled
this just shows you right use if you
were conservative you said this just
shows you we need to feed the baby she
said this just shows you how important
it is
to kill more of the babies we got a baby
formula shortage what's the answer to
that you can either make more food or
kill more babies and this woman actually
says quote there's a national shortage
of baby formula that means babies are
going hungry instead of taking care of
our nation's children
conservatives are worried about banning
abortions sickening
and this is actually in her defense this
is the left argument for abortion the
left's argument for abortion is if a
baby might suffer ever
if a baby if if a baby might have any
hardship in his life it would be better
to kill that baby
than to let him live and be adopted by
parents or or whatever their argument is
that
suffering of any kind is worse than
death and it explains the libs reaction
to abortion it explains the leb's
reaction to Suicide it explains the libs
policies on drugs actually for that
matter
explains the lib's reaction to questions
of life
now you know tomorrow is a mailbag
I'm very excited we've got this new
wonderful process where I get to hear
from you in the mailbag not just read
your questions but I will get to hear
from you you can leave voicemails in my
mailbag we will play them on the show so
make sure you become a daily wire member
to go do that also
it is the most infamous Supreme Court
case in history it is the deadliest
decision in history and even 50 years
after Roe v Wade
few know the full gruesome truth behind
that Landmark decision this decision
that has enabled the destruction of over
64 million babies since 1971 well
tomorrow May 13th the daily wire will
take a wrecking ball to all the four big
lies that the abortion industry is built
upon tune into the world premiere
of our original documentary featuring
Yours Truly called choosing death the
legacy of Roe uncover the inside story
of how Roe v Wade came to pass and why
it needs to pass away here's the trailer
um many times when we
did this
as we started uh
patients would
begin crying and
protesting
but once we had begun dilating the
cervix and passing instruments into the
uterus was too late to stop
[Music]
I was handing hush money
to women who we had left pieces of their
baby we had put these women's lives in
Jeopardy we'd put their lives at risk
and we were literally giving them a
check for eight hundred dollars
and for a poor woman eight hundred
dollars a lot of money
there have been so many moments in the
last decade plus of going undercover and
abortion clinics myself and seeing just
heartbreaking things women vomiting in
the hallway of an abortion clinic crying
out in pain the late term abortionist
talking casually about how they would
literally leave a born alive baby to die
or if you deliver the baby in the toilet
then you pick it up and stuff it in a
plastic bag and bring it to us
babies are being born alive
and the backs of their necks are being
slit they are being drowned their necks
are being snapped it's it's happening
more often than people want to think
about
these abortion facilities these abortion
providers these doctors
they don't care about these women
and you're just you're realizing that
you're watching in front of your own
eyes play out America's greatest Horror
Story
which is
how we butcher children in the name of
choice
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
the truth tell your friends to watch if
you are not already a member become one
today dailywire.com tune in Friday to
the documentary choosing death the
legacy of Road dailywire.com
choosing head on over there right now to
join the fight we'll be right back with
a lot more
thank you
we've got food shortages we've got
inflation at record highs we've got gas
prices at record highs we've got
immigration especially illegal
immigration at record highs we've got
the first major war in Europe since
World War II we've got
lots and lots of problems nothing is
going right for Joe Biden and yet Joe
Biden insists that this is his strength
and I agree with what chairman Powell
said last week that the number one
threat is the strength and that strength
that we built is inflation
the number one
threat is the strength
and the strength that we've built is
inflation now I'm
I think that might be true I think I
think fact check true on it then the
number one threat is the strength okay
what is it strength isn't a threat right
but what do you okay what do you mean by
strength you're saying the strength is
that you have built is inflation well
you did build inflation you are one of
the principal drivers of the inflation
crisis we have right now and that is the
number one thread so I guess he's
telling the truth probably unwittingly
probably because the teleprompter was
too difficult for him to read or
something but I think Joe Biden actually
may have just accidentally said the most
honest thing he's ever said in his
entire career yes this is the threat
this is a major threat to the country
disproportionately to people at the
lower end of the socioeconomic spectrum
and it's a big threat to his presidency
and it's why the Democrats are Running
Scared here I think it's why in large
part they tried to shift away from the
economic problems to a cultural issue
like abortion and then abortion didn't
work for them then it turned out that
was actually a loser too so now they're
trying to shift and say Republicans want
to get rid of contraception they're
making this argument they're saying if
we have a real Roe v Wade then they're
going to overrule the Griswold decision
which found a constitutional right to
contraception they're gonna they're
gonna Outlaw interracial marriage
they were truly grasping at straws
because they know
that this is a loser they know that the
midterms right now unless there is
widespread voter fraud
which there might be is a great new
movie out by Dinesh D'Souza called 2000
mules I actually haven't seen the whole
movie yet so I want to wait to comment
on until I can finish the movie but
there's you know as we've said
especially on this show as we've said
from the very beginning since election
night 2020 lots of questions about that
election lots of weird stuff lots of
obvious violations of the law in certain
States and how the election was
conducted huh it's kind of that's not
good if we don't get our election
security under control then we're not
going to it's not going to matter how
much momentum we have going into the
midterms or into 2024 but assuming that
we can get that under control which we
have in certain States at least uh it's
going to be a blowout
assuming nothing changes it's going to
be an absolute blowout for Joe Biden and
for the Democrats I think a lot of
people right now are looking back on
those Trump days those days of
Republican rule quite fondly
I think I think people want Trump back
if not in the white house so probably
that too but if not in the White House
certainly on Twitter which is why Elon
Musk is now saying this is really
breaking news Elon Musk is saying he
will he would gladly reinstate Trump's
Twitter account
I guess the answer is that I I I would
reverse the Perma ban I would say I'm
not I don't own Twitter yet so this is
not like a thing that will definitely
happen because what if I don't own
Twitter but my opinion and Jack Dorsey I
want to be clear shares this opinion uh
is that we should not have permit
permanent ads
okay great
then why is he doing this one because
it's the right thing to do Elon made
this point explicitly said I think it
was morally wrong to ban Trump but he's
also doing it this is a real message if
you're not a true Rock ribbed
conservative constitutionalist Patriot
whatever word you want to use
at least let me appeal to your self or
interest right now
the issues that conservatives are
running on are winning issues
having the ability to speak freely on
social media that's a winning issue the
libs have a losing position on that the
conservative said what winning position
pro-life pro-life or pro-abortion look
at that vote yesterday in the Senate the
pro-life side is the winning argument
here
okay
the restricting immigration that is a
winning argument poll after poll after
poll shows it
the Stop Printing money it's sending it
to all people all over the world and
actually maybe Focus your resources at
home that's a winning argument
stop letting Dr fauci govern the country
get rid of all the stupid coveted stuff
that's a winning arguments all the
conservative arguments are winning even
just from yourself
interest you should be siding with the
conservatives if you're in the middle if
you're a squish if you're an independent
it is in your interest to side with the
conservice for goodness sakes even
Whoopi Goldberg agrees on this point
especially on the point that Elon just
made Whoopi Goldberg on The View she is
a very left-wing lady she just said yeah
if Elon wants to put Trump back on
Twitter that's probably the right thing
to do
listen Donald Trump wants to be on
Twitter if people want to listen to him
fine
because that's what it is that's where
we have said to people you have the
right to say whatever you want to In
This Place we've Let It Go and when it
suited us it was fine and when it
doesn't suit us it's a problem
so right Wolfie you tell him that's
right yes if people want to listen to
Donald Trump who is by the way who is
not some Fringe radical extremist danger
he's a former president of the United
States for goodness sakes he's been a
celebrity for 40 years he's a very
well-known cultural figure if people
want to hear from him they should be
able to hear from him it's not just
crazy right Wingers who think that a lot
of liberals think that too a lot of
Democrats think that too that's why the
Democrats are getting crushed in the
polls right now
you want to talk about issues of Freedom
Senator Cruz just proposed a phenomenal
new bill this is the wait for it it's
the allowing military exemptions
recognizing individual concerns about
new shots Act of 2022. also known as the
Americans Act
that boo boo Senator Cruz that that
acronym is too good it's too good you
know politicians love acronyms that's a
really good one and it's a really great
build
Senator Cruz and a group of 13 Gip
senators and it is so 14 total I have
introduced this bill to protect military
service members from punishment for
declining to get the fauci ouchy this is
a good idea because Joe Biden wants to
punish conservatives largely
conservatives but anyone who has an
opposition to taking this experimental
drug that doesn't do what everyone told
us it was going to do to protect against
the virus which isn't nearly as bad as
everyone told us it was going to be
which is just to protect people from
having medical experiments done on them
okay especially our service members
seems like really basic stuff and there
have been lots of military members
who've been discharged already over this
issue
so this bill would protect them allow
them to go back into the service this
bill would protect people who were still
holding out in the service
who don't want to take this dumb shot
really great stuff
it's the right thing to do Senator Cruz
I mean I know this person like as we
host a show together and we've been
talking about this from the very
beginning he has always been on the side
of this issue or he's always been saying
no we shouldn't no one should be forced
to take this shot but definitely not the
service members now there might be with
the elections coming up there might be
an opportunity to to push this through
uh certainly by the time the the next
Senate rolls around uh every Republican
should be running on this every
Republican not only because it's the
right thing to do but because it's a
winning issue the reason I brought David
Pacman on the show today was not to
debate abortion we debated abortion with
Bronte remsick last week you can go
watch that debate it's on it's online I
felt she gave a very honest view of her
ghastly side of the argument I
appreciated her coming on the reason I
brought David Pacman on today is because
I know that he's got some at least
reasonable political instincts here and
I wanted to see David are you going to
defend people showing up at judge's
homes and screaming and shouting are you
going to defend this extra political
kind of you know vandalizing pro-life
centers are you going to defend
Democrats running on the issue of
abortion
and to his credit he said no I'm not I'm
not it's a bad idea don't do it guys
come on back off it I hope that the
Democrats don't get the message I hope
Republicans hold firm I hope a lot of
people in the middle catch what's going
on right now and see these two visions
of the country and side with the people
on the right I'm Michael knowlesus the
Michael Knowles show see you tomorrow
[Music]
the Michael Knowles show is produced by
Ben Davies executive producer Jeremy
boring supervising producer Mathis
Glover production manager Pavel vidovsky
editor and Associate producer Danny
D'Amico associate producer Justine
Turley audio mixer Mike coromina and
hair and makeup by Cherokee heart
Michael Knoll show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2022.
John Bickley here daily wire
editor-in-chief wake up every morning
with our show morning wire where we
bring you all the news that you need to
know in 15 minutes or less join me and
my co-host Georgia Howe for daily
coverage of all the biggest stories on
morning wire
[Music]